o sol 50 mais um vídeo de hoje vou
tentar fazer 16 65 pisando uma folha
como está aqui e eu vou dar preferência
para fazer todas as peças que o piso mas
vocês não tiverem nos preocupa vocês
podem fazer o mesmo processo outras a
motocicleta daquelas pequenininhas vamos
dar a volta atrás da concorrência e
outras coisas vocês vão ver ao longo do
filho ou seja se eu fizer alguma coisa
da editora três de vocês conseguem tirar
essas peças de bicicleta pequena que
você estiver lá em casa e agora vamos
lutar por mudar o google sketchup é um
programa gratuito que vocês podem baixar
em aprender a usar facilmente um dia uma
vez que tem muita informação online
disponível salienta que no youtube ou
induzi ensina o básico eo programa
bastante fácil de usar já os outros e
isso que é dos mais fácil seria melhor
por acusar vocês quiserem ter acesso às
mídias sociais que eu vou usar aqui
neste vídeo tem que mandar uma mensagem
para minha página do facebook e depois
enviá los por ter mais poderosa sentado
no veículo
por acorrentados em profusão número 4 e
umas placas sociais têm uma borracha
azul que faz com que o profundo não
perca a porta em movimento não funcionar
muito vai então teresópolis dentadas
investindo dentro naturalmente mas mesmo
assim não ficou perfeito então consegui
fazer os modelos 3d piloto
desta vez fiz duas placas para cada roda
dentada curricular e usando supercor
estudo uma peça única durante de fazer
desta maneira para achar a peça mais
limpa ou seja se um imprevisto uma peça
única queria usar material de suporte
que ela quer deixar algumas imperfeições
podem ver que fazem profundo é muito em
caixa nem aproveitam desta roda dentada
pequenina
estou muito impressionado com o curta
deste material eu andei em cima destes
cai em toda teresina conseguiu michels
que inteiro estava concentrada nela e
conseguiu aguentar as travagens bruscas
que eu fiz as quedas tudo emprego
enganar outra vez nas quartas são iguais
porém elas não encaixa muito uma da
outra isso acontece porque não fiz os
fundos nelinha que passa a ter maior
pelo meio depois por dentro lá de baixo
ou seja você tem que colocar os furos
nessa linha e depois querem ter mais
dois furos tem que fazer uma linha
pretende colar essa seja a 90 graus aqui
e fazer um furo e outra aqui e claro a
distância dos fundos dos centros em
setembro igual
e funciona eu fiquei muito políticas
nesta fase iv porque eu vou usar esse
sistema possui 500 projetos em meu
quarto e que esse material é mesmo muito
do cristiano
comprei que duas placas de contraplacado
mesmo uma tag um metro por 38 tem um
metro 35 popular uma em cima da outra
inicialmente a idéia era usar só uma
camada mas como eu estava fraca também
popular uma em cima da outra usando cola
muito importante encontrar outra para
cola aprender lá em nome da bancada e
estranho porque mais para frente é um
espetáculo roda que não tem aquela
máquina que faz mesmo furos e então eu
fico e deixar as peças de plástico
dentro destas peças aqui porque já ficam
um pouco chato sempre a mesma coisa e
mandar mensagem para minha página
encaixar tudo de comprimento e quatro de
diâmetro
no final é muito importante aprender em
tudo usando essas portas sociais tenham
borracha
desta forma mesma rotação isto é que não
se vai deportar depois cortei os tetos
profundo ficou para fora usando uma
serra para metal e foi instrumental
anuais que estréia em 8 milímetros e
como vocês podem ver funcionando muito
bem e funciona muito bem porque a roda
não chegou para os lados ficavam da e
falharam em fim dessa forma conseguem
ver que mais fica só uma linha
[Música]
já
o
[Música]
tudo
o
i
[Música]
dantas
o software do fim o que acontece no
estado de espírito que como acabaram
dando problema foi a roda ficou
transformada então se vocês quiserem
projeto de uma aula começa aqui custa
mais ou menos cinco anos e vocês podem
comprar em qualquer casa de ferramentas
o número dois desse vídeo aqui ou seja
uma opção número 2 nestes casos o que eu
vou mudar algumas peças e voltar esta
bola lá e vamos estar alguns cidade
máximo porque os átomos trek foi a
velocidade média e também como será o
alcance que vocês conseguem ter usando
uma bateria desta descobrir assistido
até a próxima vez que tiver alguma
sugestão dá uma coisa para fazer no
próximo ficar estou deixando os
comentários